burger king uk tweeted women belong in
the kitchen
on international women's day and then
like followed up
they made it like a thread that was like
i guess the initial intention was that
they were like
it was supposed to be for shock value
and they were gonna follow up and be
like if they want to the second tweet
was like
the the whole thing about it was that it
was not even clever a little bit you
know what i'm saying
no no like i thought they were gonna
like turn it into some pun or like
a joke but the only like the only
response to that was from them was if
they want to
if they want to
[Laughter]
if they want to women belong in the
kitchen if they want to
if they want to belong in the kitchen
what are you saying no
sense makes no [ __ ] sense
babe do you want to belong in the
kitchen for a little bit make me
something
i was thinking this whole weekend you
could belong to the kitchen
huh
[Laughter]
yeah i think for international women's
day it might be cool if you belonged in
the kitchen
for just like a few hours however you
long it however however long you want it
to
only if you want to only if you want to
what was the what was the thread what
did it say hold on let's read this
it was like oh no no no bro you know
what they did
you know their next burger is going to
be called the [ __ ] triple down
because that's what they did
they [ __ ] tripled
triple down this summer with a burger
created only by women
because here at burger king we believe
women belong in the kitchen
if they want to if they want to
what did it say can we get the you have
screenshots right luke
uh yeah where is it at
oh you might have to i'm gonna
i said women belong in the kitchen hold
on
if they want to of course yet only 20 of
chefs are women
we're on a mission to change the gender
ratio in the restaurant industry by
empowering female employees
with the opportunity to pursue a
culinary career why not just say
that like
he's gonna [ __ ] the whole thing up with
we need to go back to the 50s
bro if you want to belong that's right
can you imagine
no hold on can you imagine the ufc women
deserve to be hit
only if they want to
women's mma is a staggering three
percent
of whatever the [ __ ] statistic and here
at the ufc
we're committed to having more women in
combat sports
[Laughter]
women deserve a beating deserve to get
hit
if they want to of course they want if
they want if they want
to they want to deserve to get hit only
if they want to
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
that's funny damn
and they just deleted it it was up for
like a full day
you know whoever pressed tweet on that
had to have been feeling like i don't
like this idea man
no i bet they thought it was fire no i
bet they thought
i bet they were like this is gonna this
is gonna really like
get people's attention and this no
that's a good thing the [ __ ]
copywriter and the creative team thought
that was a [ __ ] genius idea
but that like but that like entry-level
salary person who actually had to like
type that [ __ ] out and press tweet
they were the one to be like in their
mind go
i don't think this is going to land the
way you like anticipate it
i don't i don't think i can't think
the guys for the brand please guys for
the burger king brand
it's just like it just doesn't quite
make sense like
women belong if they want to
press to eat mate it's this is going to
be
possibly the greatest thing we've ever
done
it's going to cause so much attention
because it's so polarizing it's like
gonna be upsetting at first but when
people realize what we're trying to do
here
no but that was australian no but you
see
it's smart it's smart it's like people
are going to think we're talking about
women in a derogatory sense i don't know
that sounds like allergy now i don't
know what i'm doing
no idea does you think
women's don't be outside
do you think that women belong in the
kitchen
only if they want them
for international women's day i don't
even know
i can't even do all the dlg all i know
is
this scene where does computers
multiply numbers like one
nine one nine four five six seven
that's a great that [ __ ] show was so
funny i know man
do you think that like how is
how is women's gonna sign up for the
link
if they're in the kitchen when this
tweet goes out
because that's where they belong in the
kitchen